Wow well what a night so many friends
and family and people we've worked with
over the years I kind of feel like I'm
having my bar mitzvah we're a little bit
of a roast from Steven but thank you all
again for coming tonight it's just a
joyous evening and Thank You Steven and
Matt for those kind words and thanks to
the Academy we're really thrilled to be
here tonight and we'd like to also
congratulate Cicely Tyson Lila chephren
and Marvin levy on their Oscar
and one special shout-out for our dear
friend Marvin Marvin happy birthday well
there you are because we are the first
couple to receive this honor I guess
it's only fitting that I began my career
in movies working for another creative
couple Peter Bogdanovich and Polly Platt
I had met them at a party in 1966 for
John Ford's daughter Barbara who was a
film editor and was married to Ken
Curtis
one of Ford's repertory of actors and a
good friend of my parents Peter and
Polly were in town doing a documentary
on mr. Ford and Peter was very excited
that night because a producer named
Roger Corman had just offered him his
first directing job it wasn't going to
happen right away because they still had
no script and they'd had to write it and
then they would do that back in New York
now despite the fact I was majoring in
political science at UCLA as everyone
was back then and despite the fact I
knew nothing about movies I offered to
you I offered to help Peter and Polly if
they ever came back and sure enough
about three months later my dad called
and said did you meet a guy named box
Lana vich or something at the fort party
and I said yes why he wants you to call
him for those under 30 that was how
social media worked back then someone
would call your dad on a landline leave
a message
he would write it down in a couple of
weeks later he might remember to tell
you to call that person back
so I called Peter back and he said he
and Polly were going to make this movie
called targets and would I be interested
in working on it I said can I start in
an hour and then I asked well what would
you want me to do he answered I don't
know I've never made a movie before
just come over so I did and without
knowing it I began to learn the skills
that a producer needs to solve problems
and I began to understand the challenges
in helping the director get their vision
up on the screen and this could not have
been a better starting point for me in
becoming a creative producer because
with Peter as the director and Polly as
the production designer I got to see and
solve problems from the creative side
targets was an on-the-job film school
and the best introduction the filmmaking
one could ever have I watched Peter
block and set up shots and how
brilliantly he worked with the actors
and I learned from Polly how our
producer should be hands-on in paying
attention to detail and these first
on-the-job lessons I got from them have
stayed with me to this day now I know
you're wondering about that political
science degree well I did graduate from
UCLA and was on my way to law school
when I realized I had fall in love with
the process of making movies luckily
Peter rescued me from what might have
been a very unhappy legal career when he
called and again and asked me to come to
Texas for the last picture show I
immediately accepted the job of location
manager and that's who led to being
promoted to associate producer on Paper
Moon for the rest of the 70s I was lucky
to do several more pictures with Peter
and three other visionary directors
Walter Hill one of them
and a couple of other guys named Orson
Welles and Martin Scorsese but they're
not here tonight and I was also lucky to
be mentored by legendary producers Larry
Gordon who was here tonight
Irwin Winkler and George Lucas and on
the personal side I was single and
happily married to the movies that I was
making and then in 1979 Steven changed
all that when he hired Kathy to be his
secretary assistant on Raiders of the
Lost Ark I never dreamed I would meet
someone who loved making movies as much
as I did but working with Steven Kathy
and I became friends and collaborators
and eventually we became an actual
family thank you all again for this
wonderful honor and celebration and
thanks to all the producers and
directors who have given us this
opportunity to take this joyful journey
together and pursue the passion we love
making movies and telling stories and in
particular thank you to Peter
Bogdanovich for his trust and loyalty in
me we're still working together half a
century later after he took a chance on
me and how fitting is it for us to have
just produced our tenth picture together
the completion of Orson Welles his final
film the other side of the wind
and now I'm going to pass the baton to
my partner in movies and in life
Kathleen Kennedy
yeah I'm not sure I'm going to recover
from the couch story yes well I have to
say it's pretty amazing to be standing
here obviously with Frank and Steven and
realizing that we now join the company
of so many greats that have received
this award in the past filmmakers such
as William Wyler Jack Warner Stephen
Francis Coppola Alfred Hitchcock George
Lucas legends all and both of us are
very proud that you find us worthy to be
honored as part of this Hollywood legacy
it also means a lot to have both Matt
and Steven here to present the award to
us I don't know what happened to Matt
but I think he's still here
and we're very honored to share the
Thalberg award as the first married
couple I'm also very proud to be the
first woman to accept this award
but I'm also not the first to deserve it
and I'm a hundred percent sure I'm not
the last I've always loved the movies
and I've been enthralled by the power of
story Stephen said this when he accepted
the award 30 years ago that power begins
with the written word
I feel extraordinarily lucky to have
worked with some of the best
screenwriters and directors in the
business and also to have witnessed so
many advances in technology to help tell
those stories but those advances are
only made powerful and emotional in
their support of storytelling that pluie
blueprint those words set everything in
motion and without great writing we have
nothing to produce
when I began working with Stephen he
handed me a script for his next film he
said read this it's my next movie but
don't tell anybody anything and that
directive is pretty much what he tells
you every time he hands you anything
that script was Raiders of the Lost Ark
written by Lawrence Kasdan and remains
today one of the best scripts I've ever
read when I finished this reading the
script Steven was waiting expectantly to
hear what I thought I said it's great
but how are we gonna make this and he
said call producer Frank Marshall so I
called mr. Marshall I called him mr.
Marshall repeatedly until he said could
you please stop calling me that I'm
Frank he then offered to come over to
our offices and introduce himself I was
expecting this much older man maybe
mid-50s but in walked this handsome
young guy and I have to admit my first
reaction was hello mr. Marshall
[Applause]
so after some back-and-forth I told
Frank that Stephen asked me to build
some models of the truck chase in
Raiders but I confessed I hadn't done
much model building Frank was
immediately excited and agreed to help
me he loved building models so to quote
Humphrey Bogart's line in clot to Claude
Rains in Casablanca it was the beginning
of a beautiful friendship that
friendship is now actually in its 32nd
year of marriage and 40 and 40 years of
collaboration and I'm so grateful to
share a career and a home with someone
whose character and convictions his
decency and humor are an evidence every
day and as proud as we are of our movies
we have two wonderful daughters who are
the heart and soul of our lives
[Applause]
when they were little we would throw
them into backpacks and carry them
through the redwoods while making
Jurassic Park or sometimes we would
create school rooms on the set of
Indiana Jones and during our time away
we have worked tirelessly in tandem to
watch them grow and to make sure that
their lives are defined by creativity
quality and most of all kindness these
are the same values we bring to our
filmmaking and the same values the
Thalberg award must always continue to
represent I've been fortunate to have
had the chance to work with
extraordinary people to help reinforce
those ideals my mother my father Frank
and of course Steven Steven Frank and I
formed Amblin entertainment in 1981 with
a goal that I think would make mr.
Thalberg proud to tell hopeful story
stories about triumphs of the human
spirit and the ability to rise above
circumstance and even with all the
exciting changes happening within film
and motion pictures with all the tools
being invented that helped us tell those
stories those fundamental values that I
look for and strive for will never
change but we all know there are changes
in our industry that should be embraced
ones that must be embraced for as our
industry grows and changes who gets to
tell their stories needs to grow and
change as well
I know firsthand how allowing new voices
at the table can change someone's life
my opportunity to work in television was
the result of a lawsuit back in 1973
filed against a station because women
did not occupy any technical jobs that
lawsuit opened the door for me and it is
just one reason why I so passionately
believe that each of us has the
obligation to ensure that everyone who
has a story to tell be given the
opportunity that I and many of you in
this room had and it is my hope that
with this inclusion of these powerful
new voices we might just bring the world
back to its senses just and maybe just
maybe shatter a few glass ceilings along
the way
so tonight to end this I just want to
say we are profoundly grateful to be
here tonight with all of you and I mean
it's just incredible that Oprah is here
and Quincy is here and we've worked with
Marvin levy and Stephens here and it
feels like some kind of amazing reunion
that I can't quite believe the stars
wind up in quite the way they did but
there's nothing that's more important
than to be able to experience something
like this with people that you genuinely
care about and have been a part of your
life for a long time so this is an
incredible honor and a privilege and we
thank you
[Applause]